strontium is an element that really came
into the news in the 1950s and 60s
because it's generated as the byproduct
of one of the testing of atomic bombs
now human bones contain calcium and the
chemistry of strontium is very similar
to that of calcium and when atomic bombs
went off they released the ISIS
radioactive isotope that's a radioactive
form of strontium known as strontium 19
and it became so widely dispersed in the
around the world that people's bones
children's teeth and so on became mildly
radioactive through the formation of
strontium 90 so it suddenly got this
rather threatening got this rather
threatening aspect which before it was
probably a slightly boring element that
nobody knew about and now again
strontium 90 has sort of gone away from
the news no longer does it feature in
pop songs protest songs and so on